hey what's up everybody it's your boy
Adam Richman and these are my favorite
snacks
okay first up is
oh yes the lion bar the lion bar you
know I would say this isn't my favorite
chocolate bar but I'd be lying uh yeah
that's that's a joke I'll be embarrassed
about later so the lion bar the best way
I could describe it is a hundred gram
bar uh I should probably explain what
one of those are too the 100 gram bar
was essentially Like Rice Krispies and
caramel wrapped in like chocolate and
joy and Angel tears and happiness and
that's essentially what most of this is
but with the exception of a layered
wafer like a KitKat in the middle I saw
my buddy Matt who was working on a TV
show with me in London that I love lion
bars and he was from bracknell so I
never heard him say the letter L ever
anyway might peanut butter lion balls
all the way forward but you have to have
them in a milkshake it is magnificent oh
my gosh and they're finally selling them
in America
[Music]
foreign
my father May rest in peace uh he was a
lawyer in his Law Office periodically he
or his secretary or somebody would get
one of those metal bins that were
divided like the Mercedes symbol and it
would be butter cheese and caramel
popcorn but everybody knew that the pro
move he'd take a little bit of the
cheddar a little bit of the caramel and
just shove directly into face hole but I
then found out that that combination is
known as Chicago style popcorn and now
they've actually begun to sell it
oh y'all still here sorry about that
okay and the thing is you got to just
get like just one handful and just
aggressively force it into your mouth
like your Jabba eating those weird like
frogs
I'm a professional don't buy this at
home
oh sweet Andrew Zimmer and I got them
too I got him matcha KitKat now I love a
regular Kit Kat and also people don't
realize that there's a psychological
test because if you uh bite into a
KitKat without breaking it
um stay the [__] away from me I was
gonna go regular KitKat and I watched
Andrew Zimmerman's episode of snacks
he's my mentor he's a friend he's a role
model I love him dearly he went for
these and it's the truth these things
were like Bitcoins these were nfts when
they were worth something look at this
oh man
[Music]
it's almost like the way whipped cream
kinda has a taste but not quite and then
as you chew it and you emulsify like all
of that matcha it keeps it from getting
too sweet and I would recommend these to
anyone who doesn't like things that are
mind-bendingly like Nerd candy Vibes
sweet
snacks
shout on
one
so this is really interesting I filmed
an episode of my show secret eats in
Manila and I fell in love with the
Philippines like from the first day the
colors of the jitneys the way Tagalog
sounds when it's spoken you know the
people are just so beautiful I went to
the convenience store and I saw a
vegetarian chicharron they resemble
actual chicharon about as much as I
resemble JLo but they are crispy they
are delicious faintly garlicky now
listen to the crunch I'm gonna lean down
to my mic be prepared yo can you do
something in post like shake the frame
gotta be dope ready one two three
oh it's so good so if Fritos got a
semester abroad they'd come back like
this it's just it's curved it's a little
more mature it's got some salt but it's
got layers of flavor
these are fire I can't believe y'all got
these
um
top 10 events is on the board Adam's
next snack and favorite body part nuts
my own
my own just not like in general
[Music]
of New York
only being the Providence of the
Canadian the soft pretzel the dirty
water dog or ambiguous skewers of street
meat uh doesn't know the wide variety
that's out there there are people doing
these roasted nuts they're like these
candy coated just meteorites of just
molar destroying joy and they always
come in these bags there we go
look at that
oh wow there's a little bit of cinnamon
a whole lot of sugar
maybe a little bit of corn syrup and
honey most of the people that are
selling them are first generation
immigrants to this country that having
this card is their leg up and it's their
opportunity and I like giving those guys
business because not too many
generations ago my grandparents were
those people who knows maybe in three
generations
they'll have a regularly handsome
grandson who looks like Fred Savage on a
bender and he'll be telling you about
his snacks
oh so this one they slid in because they
Durst not throw it and as a brooklynite
I am so glad thank you thank you for
your sensitivity
on the corner of Dekalb Avenue in
Brooklyn walking distance from my old
home there is a restaurant called
Juniors and it was founded by the Rosen
family and they are the first and last
word in cheesecake they have a thousand
different varieties ranging from red
velvet to Devil's food coconut but I
like the Og man unadorned you know what
I mean boom bat I'm feeling feeling all
kinds of things right here I mean knock
this table over with the cheesecake
boner I'm rocking right now dead don't
the Judaism fool you it's like a baby or
I'm holding an apple someone elevated a
pedestal for the Liberty Bell no I'm
just kidding nothing's worse than a guy
talking about his dick
[Music]
I haven't had in a while because I'm
trying to preserve the sexy
but look at that I mean it looks almost
like cream cheese and it keeps this
custardy consistency throughout Junior's
Cheesecake one of my favorite snacks and
it'll be one of yours too if you try it
so try it I'll see you in Brooklyn save
me a slice
stack please
Entenmann's I was and I'm the host of
Modern Marvels and we filmed at the
Entenmann's Bakery in Albany they have
something I'm trying to find it on the
box that I might show you it's called
the OU seal which means that it's part
of it's not Kosher first through ninth
grade I went to a religious Jewish
school I speak fluent Hebrew I know you
may not think that about
and based on the fact that I he was
going to this school these were the
preferred desserts you could bring these
chocolate chip cookies are legends Miss
Center yourself she mandated that these
cookies are cooled by air not by a fan
so they're these massive conveyor belts
of cookies like a river of cookies that
runs through two warehouses and it is
straight up Willy Wonka Vibes and do you
know that they even quality control each
box and the way they do it they stack a
few of them and they call it the bones
and they cut through to see where it's
firmer and where it's softer so you
could essentially just cut straight
through
what I'm from Brooklyn y'all didn't know
relax you know I keep that thing on me
it's going be high so it's firmer on the
inside a little softer on the outside
[Music]
they're amazing and this is a company
that's existed since 1898 and it's not
Hershey's and it's not Heinz and it's
not this big name but the reputation is
massive and you owe it to yourself to
try them
[Music]
thank you so much for enjoying some of
my favorite snacks with me I'm honored
to be the newest member of the first we
Feast family and if you haven't listened
to my podcast with first three feasts
the meals that made me it's available
wherever you get your podcast and yes
I'm a television meat puppet food that
built American season 4 started February
19th you can watch it Sundays 9 8
Central and then coming up later this
year I have another really cool show
with History Channel called the rebels
That Built America I'll see you you can
see me delete some snacks
[Music]